welcome back to new rockstars one
division left the mcu with more people
casting spells than wearing high-tech
suits of armor
like an av club party being overtaken by
larpers my kind of party but
we all know larpers they inevitably turn
on each other so
are we looking at a war of witchcraft in
the mcu
well i'm eric voss this is rogue theory
with me today is an amazing panel
starting with a returning guest host and
producer at kind of funny vids
blessing addie oh yay hey blessing hey
how's it going thanks so much for having
me
yeah glad to have you back i think i
wasn't here the last time you were on
rogue theory so i'm glad we get to do
this now
we got matt acevedo welcome back what's
up everybody good to be back man
yeah good to have you and new rockstar's
own off-screen producer brandon
brandon barrick i was a barrick i'm
sorry i know who you are
you know who i am i'm happy to be back
on screen for one more round
of rogue theory and then you're done
you're done
seriously after this maybe it's time to
retire
i mean yeah you just do one season
you're out i get it
all right it's the finale of one
division this past weekend
and a lot happened in it but among the
many details
were when agatha said that the scarlet
witch has the powers that now surpass
the sorcerer's supreme
in a way it felt like she was laying
down the gauntlet for doctor strange
if he was eavesdropping on this call to
be like what hold on what excuse me
uh and now agatha's still alive and the
mcu just has more and more sorcerers
witches and wizards
and we have wanda and we have agatha
added to a roster of doctor strange
immorto
and wong whoever else survived that
in-game final battle i believe
the ceo of fortnite was one of those
wizards doing a cameo so he's a wizard
in the mcu and of course
jimmy wu with his masterful sleight of
hand and that magic smile of his
that guy's a wizard in other ways and
witches and wizards are
being debated by the falcon winter
soldier even in the latest teaser if you
caught that
uh and we also know that mr dell and
spider-man far from home was terrified
of witches
so magic is everywhere and uh so
my question for all of us to kind of go
rogue on and try to figure out together
are we looking at a sorcerer battle
coming perhaps in doctor strange the
multiverse of madness
what do we think the uh allegiances the
rivalries
what are what's the battle line gonna be
in the world of wizards in the mcu
oh man uh i think honestly on a grand
scale
for a while i was thinking like the next
thanos is gonna be like kang or
something but i think the next
like big bad of the next phase is going
to be
you know some demon or something like
that like
like uh like mephisto you know i don't
think we're gonna get the next movie
i don't think we're gonna get that but i
think like especially with the next day
i honestly don't but i think in the next
like even spider-man and stuff like that
we're gonna be dealing with some weird
stuff
i think it's gonna be building towards
mephisto i don't think we're gonna get a
multiverse madness but
uh i think the alliances that we could
see in multiverse of madness
is i think wanda is messing with some
magic that she doesn't really understand
uh and i kind of think that that's gonna
leave too i i forgot the name of i
don't know how to pronounce this name i
always say like chathan or
no one knows how to pronounce that name
i never know
but he is you know he is a demon that is
that is
uh in the comics has been known to like
to use wanda
as a way to like kind of puppeteer her
let like let her get stronger let her
use like that magic so i think she's
gonna get a little bit manipulated
so she might be on her own side in this
next movie with dr strange trying to
intervene
but then mordo's gonna be the third
force which will cause you know doctor
trains will in turn help wanda
uh they'll figure that [ __ ] out and then
you know
fight mordo i think mordo's gonna be the
big bad in the next movie he's
definitely gonna be a threat i mean that
guy when he said too many sorcerers you
know it was like
forever ago it's one of those
post-credits scenes where it's like oh
right that exists adam warlock is still
coming but like
with with mordo coming back with chill
chihuahua edgar ford
i believe is confirmed for multiverse of
madness that
means that like whatever his character's
trajectory was
is going to be important to this plot
and that guy hates other sorcerers he
he's like the club's too big he hates
sorcerers who are good at basketball
that's why he took out my boy pangborn
yeah paintboard penguin had had great
style on the court
that wasn't magic that was just natural
talent i can't argue with that
man they did paintborne so dirty man so
dirt i hate to see it
i hate to see it mortal is a fun one to
bring up because i almost forgot that
mortal was a thing because we haven't
seen him since
doctor strange it all it almost reminds
me of the teas that we got back in the
incredible hulk where he got that
uh that tease for the villain that would
would have came through in the next
movie and we just never saw them again
yeah kind of i i think there's like the
smallest change that could help with
immortal but
at the same time i think by the time we
got to doctor strange marvel had kind of
figured all that stuff out
uh and so i wouldn't be surprised uh if
in the next movie doctor strange
in the multiverse madness we got a just
a range
of different allegiances in terms of uh
doctor strange maybe helping out wanda
with her magic
it very much seems like she's on the
path to figuring out what the scarlet
witch means for her
uh and how to actually control her magic
and and and use in ways that she wants
to as opposed to creating a hex out of
nowhere
uh so i think we'll see some of that i
think we'll see some of
i i wonder where on the spectrum we're
gonna see mordo
and maybe agatha land because both of
them are obviously leading towards the
the more evil side of things but i
wonder if we see agatha being more in
the middle because
when you see agatha in in one division
right like she's introduced
as this evil-ish witch that is kind of
being
handed this terrible hand because she's
being betrayed by her people and all
this different stuff i wonder if she
ends up coming back around
uh and having that realization that hey
with great power comes great
responsibility and
she's working to stop the scarlet witch
from actually destroying the world you
know as opposed to
her just being against wanda for the
sake of being against being against
wanda
but who knows i could also see a future
where maybe her and
uh mortal end up joining forces and
they're like hey we're going to use
magic
in order to stuff up and in in order to
bring our own chaos to the world i think
there's a lot of opportunity for that
yeah blessing you bring up a good point
about uh this idea of protecting people
from going too far with magic it seems
like the game that wizards have played
over the centuries was like don't let
any one of us go too far
and that was the fear with doctor
strange reading the book of cagliostro
and tapping in the dark dimension
what kaiselius was doing that was the
fear that agathis coven had about her is
that apparently she was reading this
dark hole to just
surpassing the boundary and because they
realized if you do that if you go too
far
you unleash something and i think that
was like this fear of wanda
so maybe the the game is going to be
like a war of attrition with these
wizards of like
no one uh burned the ground around them
too much because we have a reality
a nexus that we have to try to maintain
because otherwise
we could just destroy everything and i
love i just love that we're getting
we're going to flush out more of mordo
too because like
you know like like for he reminds me of
like sinestro you know because i like i
love i don't know
you know i'm combining universes here
but i mean it's the same kind of idea
where it's like
the ways we're working and he sees the
flaws and so he tries to take managers
to his own hand
uh but i like this the idea of like he's
like like
wanda like that is a big target man that
is a big
freaking target so i'm just really
excited to see him flesh out more to a
bit more
to take control of all that kind of
magic and in turn
get corrupt even more and what's gonna
happen to him i think he's gonna be
like a bit more a bit bigger too than
like just like someone's trying to
prevent
you know to take the magic he's gonna
like really turn into something else be
a manifestation of like
some demon i don't know or something
like that you know i i do also like the
idea
of this being maybe a game of three on
three basketball
where you because i i think a little bit
of okay who's going to be the big
villain
for either phase what five or in face or
phase four whatever phase we're in right
now right who's gonna be the
villain of this next saga also who's
gonna be the villain of doctor strange
in multiverse and madness right and i
think naturally we go to
agatha or we go to mordo because they've
been set up but i could see the
see it being the case where we finally
get mephisto and mephisto
is then bringing on uh agatha and
bringing on mordo
as his disciples or whatever right his
followers it is this
hey we got this team of three versus
doctor strange finding wanda and maybe
also having um uh i always forget his
name the other wizard that's part of
doctor strange's team the guy that we
all love
wong wong yeah yeah wong wong strange
and wanda kind of being the other the
other three and they're going back and
forth
that yeah i and you know what this idea
of who must be the villain and i'm
always on the mephisto train i'm
obsessed obviously with that
whole idea i want this guy to show up
but like a jack shafer did this
interview
um talking about wanda vision that came
out on deadline the day we're recording
this
and she talked about this idea of like
we didn't want a villain we wanted grief
to be the villain like want his own
grief
and then we had this kind of bonus
baddie of uh of agatha harkness
but like that idea of like people can
have
uh civilized disagreements and both
sides have valid points of view without
either one being a total villain
it's kind of that place where civil war
was in that final act where it was just
uh you know steve versus tony and
you kind of are rooting for both and
rooting for both to stop fighting
and i think the wizards can have that
kind of civilized disagreement too
i like this idea of multiverse of
madness the relationship between strange
and wanda wanda doesn't necessarily have
to be a villain
she could just be like a patient who
needs healing and then dr strange
is the ultimate healer he understands
her dilemma and can help
you know help her work through this uh
you know emotional grief that she's
going through
and then other wizards are trying to
like chip away at that with their own
you know disagreements i mean they
fought alongside each other so there's
already there's some sort there is a
little bit of history with them even
though they didn't really get much
screen time i think
they're were they both at the funeral
were they both at starks i can't
remember
yeah they were they were there so they
they know each other you know they know
of each other so it's that's
i love that theory eric of of you know
like dr strange wanting to heal
wanda because dude wanda's been through
so much i want this girl to like be
happy man
like she has not had a break you know
yeah
wanda is newly discovering so much of
this too like agatha i think brought so
much to her doorstep in terms of
hey yeah this is this is wizardry this
is uh
these are runes right this is x y and z
and wand is still learning so much and i
do like the idea that as the scarlet
witch
she is one of the most powerful magical
beings in the world which means that
it could be this fun duality of her
being brute force
her being uncontrolled powerful magic
and then doctor strange being the thing
being the person that comes through and
tries to aim that and tries to teach her
and tries to actually gain control that
i think that could make her a fun
uh dynamic between those two characters
because that makes sense i think wanda
vision really set up some
interesting ideas about magic in the mcu
especially this new idea that the
scarlet witch is some sort of prophecy
that magic wielders have been worried
about for a long time
and i know you know we love wanda as a
as a hero but i'm interested to see
wanda
go a little darker go back to her roots
of being a villain
uh and now that she has all this power
they made a good point of saying that
she's stronger than the sorcerer's
supreme i think she's gonna be the
ultimate big bad
people like mordo and agatha they're
villains but they're villains with a
heart of gold
you know they want to do the right thing
like agatha showed up because she's just
doing her magic thing and all of a
sudden
it's going crazy in new jersey and she's
like i gotta stop this like she was
trying
kind of to do the right thing maybe had
the wrong means of doing it maybe it was
a little nasty with her stuff but you
know she's old school she's from the
1600s she doesn't know how to like
communicate with the youth today uh so i
think
in multiverse of madness we might be
seeing mordo and agatha and strange
teaming up not to kill wanda i don't
want wanda dead but
bring her back to the good side yeah
i think you know magic is like the new
infinity stones right when thor was
saying you messed around the tesseract
and now all the other realms
say you're open for business i think
it's going to be that way with magic now
and all these other
magic wielders are going to show up
funny enough i feel like magic is almost
the new science now
in the mcu where over the over the years
guardian
yeah yeah right like we've we've got one
in the same you know
we've gotten hints of like gods and all
this stuff right in the mcu right and
this is the i think this is the most
we've gotten
an actual uh dedication to straight up
magic and in the way that doctor strange
kind of feels like the tony stark of the
magic side of things
i could see wanda being the peter right
and then like whoever else being
the uh the bruce banner you know like we
had so many of those smart people
early on in phase one and ongoing that
in the first saga
who have been so focused on the tech and
science side of things that now it feels
like we're starting from the ground up
with this new idea and this new stuff
we're going to see people take these
different roles
around the the magic side of things i
think too like on the on that
on those lines is like getting more into
like you know the the different realms
of like you know there's uh
of like he was dealing with like
idracial and stuff like that and like
will we see all these magic users as
well will there be like a court
of magic users from the different like
realms that that would be really really
cool
would you say maybe a magic gathering
sorry that was that was terrible i
thought it was appropriate well done
no you aren't allowed to retire yet i
don't accept your resignation
uh no i want to ask you guys yeah we are
building up to like uh
a community of uh magic practitioners am
i wrong in saying that like dr doom is
kind of a fusion of someone who uses
science and magic
like he kind of unders his science is so
advanced it kind of becomes magic at
least
the way i remember it being depicted in
the comics do we think that
like if if maybe doctor strange
multiverse of madness is strange
uh working together with these or
fighting alongside those these other
sorcerers
alongside wanda maybe some other kind of
demonic entity like nightmare or
mephisto in there
could doom show up in a third doctor
strange movie beyond that
i would love it if victor von doom
teamed up with justin hammer
uh and started making like magical
weapons
stark goes out of business stark
industries is done like no one wants
repulsor technology anymore no one wants
his nano tech
they want magical justin hammer missiles
uh
and that's how we get both hammer back
and we get victor von doom showing up as
doctor doom
i would love that justin hammer man
that's a that is i
yeah um so i think we have a good sense
of
uh the lay of the land for sure you guys
opened up a lot of possibilities here
and i really love all the theories that
came out of this uh well done you guys
are as
nerdy about these wizard arguments as i
am
uh i'm impressed i'm very impressed well
this is rogue theory still i'm still
gonna award points because um
everything has to have a score and uh
that's just how my brain works
so uh brandon for that sweet sweet magic
the gathering
button there you get one golden sparkle
that's what i get it for i'll take it
under yeah yeah well that will be that's
kind of like your legacy oscar win it's
really
that's your departed best picture oscar
right beautiful or best day
you can't stop now brandon you got you
gotta ride that wave man
merchandise for your consideration
um matt i'm going to give you a uh a
golden sparkle buck for this uh
court of magic user's idea i love this
idea of like a
a big council of magicians in the um
thank you oh my gosh
wow a blessing for this parallel i
hadn't thought of this before but i love
this idea of doctor strange being kind
of the tony stark figure
wanted being the peter parker figure and
magic being kind of the new form of like
stark tech
i'm gonna give you two points for that i
thought that was awesome oh yeah
beautiful
thank you i'm honored well done but well
done to all of you this what a robust
uh magical conversation we just had well
we're gonna speculate about the future
of our favorite nosy neighbor agatha
in just a moment but first we want to
give some thank you to the folks who
helped us make rogue theory this week
starting with
our friends at luchu so thank you to
bluetooth for sponsoring this episode
bluechew has a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients
as viagra in cialis but in a chewable
form
that is that of the fraction of the cost
so bluechu is an online prescription
service so no doctor's office or
pharmacy trips it ships directly to your
door in a discreet package
you sign up at bluechu.com consult with
one of their licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you receive
your prescription within days
their licensed medical providers work
with you to find the right ingredient
and strength and if you hate swallowing
pills good news
blue chew is well it's in the name it's
chewable you know
so there you go you can just like you
know your favorite vitamins you had as a
kid
uh now you get your favorite vitamin as
a grown up so if you could benefit from
some extra confidence when it's time to
perform visit bluechew.com for more
details and important safety information
and we've got a special deal for our
audience try bluetooth for free when you
use our promo code of rogue at checkout
you just pay the five dollars of
shipping so that's bluetooth.com promo
code rogue to receive your first month
for free and again we thank bluetooth
for sponsoring this episode we also want
to thank our friends at stereo so new
rockstars is excited to partner with the
stereo app on weekly live shows
download the stereo app for free right
now at stereo.com
new rockstars this week our stereo show
schedule
is a little different so make sure that
you are following the new rockstars
account to see our show schedule
and uh get the notification when we go
live
but there's gonna be a lot to talk about
with uh the falcon the winter soldier
series
we're gonna be taking your questions
we're gonna hear your theories and
predictions and maybe even
getting some of uh your best zemo
impressions
who knows it's live it's gonna be nuts
off-screen producer zach will probably
make a solid gold lock prediction that
will definitely not come true
you gotta tune in to find out uh mt and
i are gonna be doing our uh
falcon winter soldier after show on
inside marvel it's just gonna be like
what we did with one division with the
with mandalorian you know we love doing
these after shows and then breakdowns
the next day and you can listen to our
after show live on stereo the next
morning earlier before it comes out on
youtube so that's great also you can go
back and hear all of our previous
episodes of any of our shows on the
stereo app a lot of weird stuff has been
discussed so
some gold in there access these live
shows share your questions and theories
and interact with us
in real time by downloading the free
stereo app at stereo dot com
rockstars that stereo dot com slash new
rockstars all right uh folks back to
uh wanda vision and specifically what's
next for agatha harkness
because one division ended with wanted
trapping agatha in this kind of
trance as nosy neighbor agnes in west
view
it was almost kind of a cruel twilight
zone black mirror kind of
fate for this character because even
though the
hex closes and it ends jack
shafer confirmed in this interview that
came out that
no agatha's probably just still in this
cycle in this routine in west view
making cookies
while other people in west view new
jersey their life goes on they're
probably like look at that psycho who
still thinks the play is going
uh so what i want to know from you guys
is
what's going to happen to agatha next
like where are we going to see her next
what is her
role going to be in the mcu because i
have to assume she's gonna be coming
back in some way
he wants to go i got i got i got a bomb
so you guys go whoever wants to go first
i can go first yeah i i think it's it's
definitely a guarantee that she'll be
back and the question is
how and the easiest solution to bring
her back i can think of would be is
if uh doctor strange saying the next
movie needs
some more input or needs some insider
info maybe doctor strange on his quest
to figure out how to help wanda
or how to stop stop the scarlet witch he
realizes that he needs to go beyond
uh what his connections are in the
wizardry world and is like i do need to
find a witch
to help me out i need a witch to fill me
in and that's where he discovers
uh that agatha exists and that he can
access agatha
uh through hitting up westview and in in
finding her that way
uh and ends up unlocking her in order to
have that conversation and bring her in
the full to help her stop
scarlet witch maybe in the next movie i
think that's the easiest way to do it
um i think there's there are probably a
few other ways right mordo could also be
uh be in it mordo could also be on a
quest to cause havoc or cause chaos or
take out all wizards or whatever his
quest may be
and then maybe he's the one that finds
agatha and unlocks her by casting a
spell and bring her into the fold
i can see either of those two being the
case i like that that's good i just
wonder if like agatha gets to keep the
house with ralph boner or like
she has to go find her own house now
like she's just stuck in the town and
she assumes she lives there
uh i still think there's something up
with dottie i know we got like her name
her real name but dottie just seems very
mysterious
and secretly powerful and i i don't know
and where's the rabbit
what's the rabbit doing is the rabbit
gonna help get agatha
out of it um i think you know i said
earlier i think we're maybe done seeing
the
evil side of agatha and she's more here
to help
and especially if she's stuck in this
prison of her own mind is she having the
nightmares that wanda used to have like
all the other towns people were
you know this could drive her insane uh
so
it would be interesting to see how she
comes out of this trance
and what she's like afterwards that's uh
i kind of think that
you know because monica and
sword have made it in they literally saw
this woman
like doing doing which stuff in the sky
like this is not an ordinary person
uh i kind of think that even though she
is now thinks that she's a different
person
she's going to be taken in by sword uh
and
she's actually going to do i i think i
kind of think that someone's going to
start the pleasant hill program which
was
uh like a story arc that happened like
four years ago in the comics
where they maybe see that maybe that
agatha's actually doing maybe she's
doing okay
maybe she's like oh she's like living
her life as this person so it's like
what if we take some of these villains
and like
we brainwash them again uh and make them
think that they're other people which
leads to that storyline but
maybe her magic is the thing that like
tricks trickles out and like you know
gets everyone to realize that it's like
not real kind of like what's going on
here but like
more more government more like
manipulative
uh like you know maria hill is a big
part of it but i think that like
i don't think she's just gonna walk away
i don't think that like if if i was
if i was like monica or jimmy and i saw
this like which fly in the sky
like i'm like dude like we gotta do
something about this person yeah stop
this person
the thing i like most about this theory
is the idea that yeah
the sword are just like yo let's just
brainwash the villains and somebody
driving
driving down their street sees the
milkman and the milkman turns around
into thanos
somehow i lose i just love that idea
it's like
daddy thanos like you know like making
food yeah
thanos should have a restaurant in west
view oh yeah
spices food famous and spices
did they get the broadcast of agatha all
along like did they get to see that song
and see that there's this magical witch
in westfield you know did darcy get to
see that uh or anyone that was anyone
watching the broadcast at that point
oh that is a good point because at that
point we didn't really
see any new episodes after the episode
seven you know modern family
era of it yeah right right because i
mean you do have a good point that
sword's not going to just like
walk away from this town or the fbi for
that matter and this is
going to get through yeah this is the
one woman that like didn't have a
driver's license or anything so i'm sure
they're probably like hey what's going
on
uh agnes and she's just like okie dokie
and they're like this lady is crazy
this might also be a bit of a stretch
because like you know the fantastic four
are coming and and
like for a little bit uh agatha was like
the nanny for
uh franklin richards which is uh you
know the the omega level mutant
uh son of um susan and uh and reed you
know so
so that's a bit of a stretch but maybe
like reid's like uh
yeah you know uh we could do we need a
babysitter you know and uh she's
brainwashed she's fine she seems to have
powers that we could tap into whenever
we want because i'm reid richards and i
make stuff happen
you know yeah so maybe it's like maybe
she becomes their nanny i don't know
well there's a lot of talk about a jimmy
wu spin-off like people want to see a
jimmy woo
agents of sword kind of show i'd totally
down for that i'm
down to see just an agatha mini series
of her
like something that feels like charmed a
little bit
of her just like rebuilding her coven
and just like showing her
throughout either throughout history or
now just like as a fish out of water
trying to break out of this trance and
just like rebuild uh
witches and build a team of people and
then uh deal with like the infighting uh
desperate housewives style
in that time because that is wisteria
lane right isn't that westview is that
the same with steering light yeah
yeah so why not it's uh it's also
gilmore girls isn't it
yeah it's right yeah that's the
crossover we've been waiting for
yeah well and to your point brandon like
dottie her real name is sarah proctor
which was the name of a
a girl who was accused of witchcraft in
salem in real world history so there
might be a connection there
that might be something they're being i
mean emma caulfield is wasn't she part
of buffy back in the day
yeah she was in uh she was in buffy
girl anya yes she was like a demon
yeah that now that you've said that i
realized that's her okay
okay that's crazy yeah i did not put two
and two together that's great
the two of them her and uh and katherine
hun could totally
like have a show they'd be great i don't
think i don't think we've seen the last
of west view for sure
seems like there's so much going on with
it i definitely think that catherine han
is just such
she's like in my opinion one of the best
memorable villains in the mcu i
i kind of think she's gonna get the loki
treatment like she's gonna keep
reappearing
like maybe we'll see a multiverse
version of her who knows but i think
we're she's not gone we're gonna see her
a lot more than we think i hope so
because i think i think that's a good
way to kind of build villains over time
one of my critiques with the mcu over
the last
i guess decade has been that a lot of
times the villains just don't hit
and i think that's because there's
always so much focus on the protagonists
in building up the actual heroes
themselves which is awesome
but villains are usually one and done
and so even even the times where we get
an amazing villain like somebody like
killmonger we're like oh this is awesome
but then he's gone after that movie and
it's like okay well
you know what who can we latch on to and
i think agatha would be a great one
uh starting now uh to have us like latch
on to in the way that we lashed on to
loki i think that could be really cool
well uh again a lot of great thoughts
here guys like there's a lot of
futures for agatha and i do want to see
some version of all of it but yeah
exactly seeing her as a loki figure
who's always just kind of a jerk
who's just serving themselves but you
love them still and you can't wait to
see what they do next
uh absolutely they need to keep her
around because she's been so great and
this character has been such a delight
all right points here we go
so uh blessed i really like this idea of
doctor strange enlisting agatha is kind
of like
an ally in whatever this sorcerer war is
going to be so you get a point for that
for sure
taking it thank you matt this idea of uh
of this whole pleasant hill project um
and that fact that the government could
use agatha to
try to lock um villains and or people in
kind of brainwashing i think that's a
great idea i'm giving you two points for
that
whoa thanks man very nice yum yum yum
yum yum
brandon i love this question at least
that you asked that
honestly blew my mind because i didn't
really think about it
who the hell was watching agatha all
along
uh because who was the audience of that
everyone was kind of in their own world
at that point
was that just for us and what does that
say about agatha and her powers
uh so i'm gonna give you just it was a
simple thing but i'm giving you two
points for it because
an amazing observation yeah that's
awesome so we are all tied up heading
into rogue questions now
guys uh so it all comes down to this uh
actually we have a couple road questions
so you have a chance to uh
uh to get ahead either way uh all right
our first to quite a road question
because of a glitch on hbo max
the other day a few lucky viewers got to
watch at least the first hour of
zack snyder's cut of justice league
early the snyder cut briefly
played when they tried to watch the new
tom and jerry movie
so uh my question for you to answer is
what is the strangest possible movie
that the snyder cut
could play during i think if you were
like sitting down to watch
you know uh little women or something
like that and you got
you got like the snyder cut i think that
would be a shocking shocking surprise
yeah you expect to get in to see tracy
let's shoot down
uh young joe's uh manuscript uh
but instead you see lots of abs
mine also is a little sexual i guess
with abs and stuff i don't know
i've actu you know but like maybe you're
watching uh the hit classic
ghost right and they're doing the
pottery scene and it's like
oh this is something's happening here
and then it like flashes to
like you know cyborg and and superman in
his
black suit that everyone's freaking out
about and stuff like that that would be
jarring because i don't think someone
who's watching ghost would really want
to watch
that you know what i mean for me i can
imagine sitting down after a long day of
work
gathering the wife and kids and being
like all right guys let's all relax
let's put on let's put on this new movie
that just came out scoob
let's watch scoob click play and all of
a sudden
superman says a bad word i don't know
how the starter cuts going to open
that's how i imagine it i imagine
superman says a really bad word the
joker comes through talks about how
lives of society
all this fun stuff uh and yeah no you
just want to watch scoob
reggie rapper and grills people
do you think if people sat down to watch
the snyder cut
of justice league and tom and jerry
started people would give it maybe like
20 minutes and thinking like wow snyder
was really on one for this
this is crazy i understand why this got
cut this is really
this is really weird it should have come
out a weird take on this like how long
do you go before you're like this isn't
it
see what they need is when you're
watching shrek and then alleluia plays
when he's crying because
and him are fighting and then that just
trigger jumps to
leonard cohen's aliyah playing over the
opening titles of snyder that would work
right that would work i do like the idea
of like you keep
you're watching tom and jerry you just
let it keep rolling because you're like
okay maybe
maybe this is it maybe this is just a
weird intro because that's the exact
thought i had towards the beginning of
wonder woman 1984
where i was like oh this is this might
be the wrong thing but i'm just gonna
let it keep playing just in case
it turned out that was the movie the
movie was just that bad yeah they wanted
the feeling of when you go to the movie
theater and you don't look at the number
of the theater you're walking into and
you're like yeah this feels weird the
audience seems like children for this
r-rated movie that's weird
yeah and you're like you're like
certainly the whip physics for wonder
woman
wouldn't be this bad this has to be a
different movie and then wonder woman
shows up and you're like oh
nope this is the right thing i didn't
like that movie
hold on
brandon i'm giving you the point for the
tom and jerry idea watching tom and
jerry
and that's just the snyder cut beginning
all right we have one more question here
uh photos from the set of thor love and
thunder show natalie portman as jane
foster
looking pretty jacked so what workout
tip did chris hemsworth share with his
co-star natalie portman to
help her pack on that musk i'm gonna go
yeah go with 100 push-ups 100 sit-ups
a 10-kilometer run basically the workout
from one punch man i don't know if you
guys seem to have seen one punch man
but there's a workout routine they do in
that anime and i think it's the exact
same routine it's basically a very
simple workout routine
i think maybe maybe chris hemsworth like
reached into his australian roots
uh and i remember seeing a documentary
called crocodile dundee
where a man wrestles an alligator or a
crocodile i guess
he's wrestling a crocodile so maybe
that's the advice he gave to natalie
portman's you gotta wrestle a crocodile
uh and you better come out on top i
think uh he was just like
they're having a really nice cup of
coffee or something talking about it
he's just like
you just do it he's like
yeah he's just just thinking and then
you just do it you know
wait you don't wake up like this
yeah exactly i had a really high
metabolism i don't know
look it happened it was like it's
anything work for chris pratt you know
uh
and guardians he just did it yeah and
natalie portman was like
yeah that's that's how have i not
thought of this ahead of time
it totally worked hemsworth dna it's in
the family
maybe he just shared you know a little
oh yeah some some dna cells with her
like a hair strand you know like yeah my
hero academia
you know take this back to the lab have
your people work on it
well uh i'm gonna give the point
to uh matt for uh that idea of just
just do it just keep it simple because i
feel like that is all you gotta do i
mean it works for nike right
so that's kind of yeah it's gonna be
something to it uh i think that makes it
a tie between
matt and brandon and they cancel each
other out making blessing the winner yes
my strategy works
i like that you get i like that
cancelled out or on sides of an equation
both are cancelled out so uh
congratulations to all of you guys this
was such a great episode i feel like we
covered a lot of ground
uh uh everyone listening to this podcast
is now
smarter uh going ahead and you can be
the smartest one in your friend's group
if you just
uh just steal something one of these
three said and just
pared it out and now people be like wow
you came up with that and be like yeah
yeah yeah
and someone else in that group they're
like he watches new rock stars the son
of a [ __ ] but he's non-confrontational
so he won't say anything so you're good
because that's what happens at av club
larping parties
people don't really have
none none at all uh that is it for this
episode of rogue theory i want to thank
our guests uh matt acevedo blessing
eriode
and uh brandon barrack you guys are
great
thanks so much for having us man it was
a blast yeah yeah so i want
to let everyone know you can support our
channel by checking out one of our many
great merch options at new
rockstarsmerch.com
if you follow me at eavos follow new
rockstar subscribe here on youtube
and a reminder to download that stereo
app going to our stereo dot com
new rockstar so you can listen to our uh
new
live shows that we've been launching
including uh an inside marvel
with uh myself and uh it's now gonna be
mt
uh talking about falcon winter soldier
i'm so excited uh and you can download
that app for free
on apple and android to create an avatar
and profile
thanks everybody we will see you next
time bye wizards
bye-bye bye just do it
[Music]
you